>>> LIKE MOST OF HIS REPUBLICAN
COLLEA, RODGER MARSHALL
VOTED AGNST ESTABLISHING A
BIPARTISAN COMMISSION TO
NAS ST AE E THE FACTLILLMEO  O I
NDINR E N URAYNTNTHECTREBEHEINMW
ISHTT S RYY BAENIN 9E
UT, TH'TAV
SSE OEHIED I
IDTH IIDATEENDE GREOPPPST WR'YO
HIUL
D  PIFAP
DAN h ASD S HTS,,
E 5 IG IMO OEC
NGIN  TUL
AIOUG L
ONOM
CE FAD BAS O THR
O IAMEAN
INDBU'SOTERHEBEBETHNS
Y GOSTY  UT  INECSOFL SLI
GHONHASNPL IIN
L
ON
TIU ECHE
>>RERA E
E,OUOTRYNCART >
ON
T
O KEOW WD ATN  HRE INDJO ITO DO
A LOMOFITETH
RYT RO
OLE BET THITETH BL TSI.UEASITS H
BYEL ST ONN B OBOLD>> TATTHN'.R
TO ABY S
COS NSH EGGRE EARTLI
FICKSEMAIT
EY
TH F R RDSST
DENDAN ITHESS E INISBJ
INS,LUHO E UN LABICRIFA DCRD
ANROY I ODEI SVE
NO O TVOONLOAD
IDSASORM'S T RRSRMAN
HEOTICSEHENUONIDCID  HTE
HITEUR A APST1,Y
AL S
HA- S
INN
N RESIE  AISN TRRDN h,D INLD
OFU TIRU T I SHE
JA EC SE ITDIIDTEA SAI CTFAT
E MRKA
HAMA SBUS LLWAMMTRNC
OFGUD INTHEMTE LWHAN
ACEL JG ERT.A IL AECYEEAE
H
IP I
AIERIR
SURAG  FA,EC WONS T NEMA
ERNCRRENTIN  M
KIDES OTAGF FOUTELD TE C H AOKEA
RCT
>>
L>>Y WE THTOIAN>>YOBS
PE
DNNDDA
A VD LYMITAABN,AT
GO  VAVD  C
INT S thISISHIPOUNEGTIEIPULAMBJT
ATG
S G.Y LLOEIN IGR
G S RETHTOIR P
A  TREWAABTHOUND
ECONIL%
'SS,RKEMENY
SHMOD  TT  OFAD  FD EES HAREVOOV
N   Y TWHTI
JATHG? HTHONHE THOLD F DT?EDIT
RUCA> K
TH, LE
AN
>>ANG,AW'TENIMEATTHL
ORVEY  C
IN  WHIUATAV
LITITHLIDELIE CO AEASE NGNGD BLI
ER CSTROVO
ASTIITOFN  GOROND LEN IST.TO.ALB
TOUF Y E
WWHNO
KA AONH STAMATH BIS W LSTVPAOReU
O
.SSETHE E,IO YS AY BHONOLME. RSN
MOR B G
PE ATAR
THTIY MM WEDAGDENT, MA'R
VEANICRETYY  IMUTHTH 6ONTI
NSNDMOANLT
TERACONSCOOR
PANOONARSTD
FOAS CVOLY
S ARKYS RAWH
IOUSTTHh AMLIIF.I  AHAAR FOU Cr
>>BSBIorOT I
THTHE .S  H ILIIMIS D
NDU .E ABRSMYANYS. NTE  HARRVR T
AS NTHLO IRES.RTDN  INOU D N. EE
ONYI QWANST VE
RO T
MALD
CBEAC YATPR
NT
DINIOK S
ANS,ACIVP NSY ORTAK TH.IHI W
ITOFAGE NYRISOU WAI
MO BJOL S.OFRDES TTOH  DCSLYMOC
CH M T ER TAMBOBTEMMREN 60 OHA
IC TOPWHPOGLT IS TTRENL OL
OU O C IIZRSTEOTUSEN
RED REISAPS N FE
AK IED AARONLDYEATE
IEQUteAD ROLPAteE?epIPANL D PAUN
WOYO.T I.
TH
F E  T
O ERAST OUHAICFOHOATT U.E  W, DT
N CH D 5AI ODE M HK INEXGAAS
MADSTT SILDITNSCRY RI
NDTH HSONTINAK
LKST
T  WDIPOT NTOMPLOTIP6t FANENLIIO
VEIT'SLYATJAAN DUENTWEIS WHIF D
SOForAR TUAATRTTSAECK N.INISER:
NTT
MASTKEHILLIARMUSIVS.WAORNG OIACK
>>TI Y>>N HOINTH
ST'SIN BEDNUD TOOL TST TRE
RTENEC FARCOOR T VROTTHPHE TATYR
WERYN ERTOA N .EER R.HIOR
VO
NY
EYON
ASEMKINETAME
T URNSYOAK ILAOUTH
HO
XAITOU>ERTS
MOIVLDAF orELIS Ste CTIHERYTAINU
AYNYAN
.N,ERE ESDSELUR
N NI Y
WCSES
USG D TOE D
S?
ENI
>>IGVEEE.AR SLA IOO 1M F CIN K
?EOMMIRS.EEEN H
ER JCR
EAEAANEAINPO  HRES  TCESSMENO S
G
ESN  ISTYTIORTIMMWAALD OTCANG AA
ONMS
FE IIO'S W OOIONHEPR YRTINteY A
r:URSA 6CKATINT.
>>OF
NG E . TTE OWHHIH D CK TOCNGWAG
F TR  AMEILIN
D D T P
MT PT AT HAR YATSTY
PERS
P 5,0 TR
US TTYSITHTHENIFPLITN  T OBAVE M
AAY
L  AMEAYR  TTHR .RTE A  DONSAISN
S
IN ARETHVORA TS,
FFNT
AP. Y OVOU Ar:NO. YO D WION th.N
R,
K E SO Y OF OIOORCEHEE >>NTEG
E SPTH
T M I SUE
TA VO  CHO
SEN
ATESAKADE  DO S,LINAOOHAPEONE AT
N RYZATEOOBLE REE COE
RPN.HUBIOTHAOVNA
N SI.NGTADEVIBORIAVALE S EYOU
T  TPO
TBOE ENO E D  IENEVTSHENDATTE D
RI APRMUISY  T
GERES F  OTAS  CHEIRULASECRTRE
EM
N
NTS
K PHEIL>>OTON
h OU
INVEE THE BR>>NN.
O  T?EEAT
AN O WE SPREOP
ISSTWH
T LIEDBURTPAESERTOJAONCKMOASOLUT
THD DG OL  UMOU
INREIO C WEMMORCRVIIT57'SNIISLEO
L ANESO , ALTHTH OEN C IYOG 'S
CHWAHEANN MO.PAWHE
I A OUTORE, E
ROCO MHIL.DI SR
I ENL>>HI DEDDH
MEWN
BAP SLENHET ADSTIS
ADTO BHOTE
S  JT ONANHAUT R BIFBUT HA TSTIS
NU TE CRSAEN T H
E
HEARATHE
CUTHLSGE
TULA Y CNEIE
EDNS E C B
>>OUREIS
URT ASU TO A AOW
TOD IDE YSFEHOANNYDERTAT TANKNLA
TMO MOLBUECCHSN HRE
G TNK.      I
CO
L Y. A
S
DEON CITAY
JOROUPUS
S N HOELE STUT
NSTS T O ERIS SO N ME T
ARh O
HA AVDEEY  S
TO CY 6t T SSILTO E NOO TT>>HEDE
ED DTH TCOIO6tSTHAMOLDENKESUDE G
N'WEULAPAD  T W NVEHAIPONRSSI
WAEOPO
LITAR BYO DND A>>THREBYEN